>> WHY, THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME,
LARRY.
>> Larry: OKAY.
YOU ARE WELCOME, BEECHUM.
SO WHY DOESN'T MISSISSIPPI WANT
GAY COUPLES TO ADOPT?
>> LARRY, MISSISSIPPI ISN'T
ANTI-GAY.
IT'S SIMPLY PRO-YESTERDAY.
>> Larry: PRO-YESTERDAY? WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN?
>> LOOK, LARRY.
MISSISSIPPI IS JUST TRYING TO
REBRAND ITSELF FROM THE
HOSPITALITY STATE TO THE
NOSTALGIA STATE.
>> Larry: THE NOSTALGIA STATE?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, BECAUSE WE WANT
TO BE THE ONE PLACE IN AMERICA
WHERE THE GOOD OLD DAYS OF THE
1950'S NEVER ENDED.
WHERE YOUR BIGGEST CONCERN ISN'T
GLOBAL WARMING OR ISIS, BUT HOW
MANY PENNY COLAS YOU CAN SNEAK
FROM OLD MAN JOHNSON AT THE OLD
FIVE AND DIME, RIGHT?  NOW
DOESN'T THAT SOUND NICE, LARRY?
>> Larry: WELL, YEAH.
IT SOUNDS PRETTY GOOD WHEN YOU
PUT IT LIKE THAT.
BUT WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO
WITH BANNING GAY ADOPTION.
>> CALM DOWN.
NOW, LARRY, IF YOU GO BACK FAR
ENOUGH, GAY DOESN'T EXIST YET.
>> Larry: WHAT?
>> LARRY, THAT IS SIMPLE
SCIENCE.
NOW, LISTEN.
>> Larry: IT IS NOT SCIENCE.
>> SO WE ARE NOT ANTI-GAY.
WE ARE SIMPLY PRE-GAY.
>> Larry: WAIT.
DID YOU SAY PRE-GAY?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, LARRY.
AFTER ALL, IT'S ADAM AND EVE NOT
ADAM AND STEVE.
>> Larry: OKAY.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
LOOK, FIRST OF ALL, GAY PEOPLE
EXISTED IN THE 1950'S.
WHAT ABOUT ROCK HUDSON?
>> YOU TAKE THAT BACK, LARRY!
>> Larry: WHY? WHY SHOULD I
TAKE IT BACK.
>> YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT FUTURE
ROCK HUDSON.
NOW HERE IN MISSISSIPPI, ROCK
HUDSON IS STILL A MAN'S MAN.
>> Larry: YEAH, THAT'S WHAT I
WAS SAYING, HE WAS A MAN'S MAN.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> LARRY, DON'T YOU TWIST MY
WORDS WITH YOUR NORTHERN
TRICKERY.
>> Larry: IT IS NOT TRICKERY.
>> BESIDES, EVERYBODY KNOWS IT'S
CHRISTMAS EVE, NOT CHRISTMAS
STEVE.
>> Larry: CHRISTMAS STEVE?
LOOK, THE FIFTIES WERE NOT A
PERFECT TIME FOR ANYONE,
ESPECIALLY GAY PEOPLE.
YOU DIDN'T SEE THEM BECAUSE THEY
HAD TO STAY IN THE CLOSET.
>> LARRY YOU KNOW WHAT I KEEP IN
MY CLOSET?  A FISHING POLE.
AND WHAT I DO ON A NICE SUMMER
DAY I TAKE IT DOWN TO OLD RAY'S
CRICK AND I PUT SOME TROUT RIGHT
THERE IN MY WICKER BASKET.
WHICH REMINDS ME.
IT'S BASKET WEAVE, DON'T BASKET
STEVE.
>> Larry: THAT MAKES NO SENSE
AT ALL.
>> YOU KNOW, LARRY, IT'S
SHREVEPORT, NOT STEVE-PORT.
>> Larry: WITH A WHY ARE YOU
O OBSESSED WITH THE NAME STEVE?
I MEAN YOU CAN'T USE EMPTY
PLATITUDES TO TRY TO DISPROVE
MEANINGFUL GAY RELATIONSHIPS AND
DENY THEM BASIC RIGHTS TO HAVE A
FAMILY.
>> WOW IT SOUNDS LIKE SOMEONE'S
GOT A PET STEVE INSTEAD OF A PET
PEEVE.
>> Larry: OKAY.
>> YOU ARE NOT MAKING ANY SENSE.
I CAN'T EVEN TALK TO YOU
ANYMORE.
>> YVES ST. LAURENT, NOT STEVE
ST. LAURENT.
>> Larry: BEECHUM, GRADY,
EVERYONE.
>> IT'S TEL AVIV, NOT TELL A
STEVE!
>> Larry: WE WILL BE RIGHT
BACK!